au cours des 50 dernières années la
population mondiale a doublé l'écart
nous sommes un million de plus sur la
planète c'est la plus grande crise de
l'histoire de l'humanité la mairie à la
fédération
la décision de ces autorités qu'un seul
enfant par famille en premier devant la
loi sur le co pas d'enfant et benjamin
roure du meilleur tour aux dépens d'une
brouillonne
vous avez pensé à des prénoms cette
fille lundi mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi samedi dimanche à partir de
demain vous allez sortir chacune votre
tour le jour de la semaine correspondant
à votre impression
tous les dimanches soit immense qui
sortira lundi sont sûrs que la vie me
situe
[Musique]
hors de ces murs
vous adopterez toute l'identité unique
de karen redman
[Musique]
autre nom qui loupait
karen fait mal auriez vous quelque chose
à déclarer non
et quoique du papier il est venu que
vous trouviez il ne faudra jamais dire à
personne que vous avez qu'est-ce qu'il
faut y aller blissy morts et si la
police pour qu'on ait pu la rater il
faut faire quelque chose pour elle il
faut sortir d'un peu fois
[Musique]
faites attention à vous prendriez un
risque d'ajouter si manger cette manne
[Musique]
manque d'eau
sans nourrir
[Musique]